okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
sorry i missed last week i was close to
being able to do it but i was traveling
and the technology didn't quite work
all right well let's see i'm happy to
try and address all kinds of questions
about
uh
elementary not so elementary science
technology whatever
we seem to have a bunch of questions
left over and let me try and see if i
can address a few of these so there's a
question here i'm always suspicious of
questions which seem like they're easy
because i'm
you know i'm i'm not i
as i get into these i sometimes realize
oh gosh there's this thing that seems
obvious to me but actually it's not
quite so obvious but uh so here's one
that uh was it's about how do induction
cooktops work without burning your hand
if you touch them and that's also
similar to questions about how um
uh wireless charging of phones and and
other such things work
okay so the big idea is this phenomenon
called electromagnetic induction which
was discovered by michael faraday back
in the 1800s
and here's the
here's the thing and it's a sort of
fundamental fact
it's that
um
magnetic fields
can
now you see this is i i knew as i got
into this i knew that um uh that we have
issues here but the um
uh
the basic the basic story here is
changing magnetic fields
can induce electric
uh currents
and
the um
uh that the the the basic idea is when
you have
a
um
when you have a changing magnetic field
you can um
you you you end up being able so what
what's actually happening the
what's happening
see see now that i i shouldn't have i
jinxed this by even saying that um
questions that seem easy often aren't
the
the the the sort of fundamental physics
of it is the physics of the
electromagnetic field
governed by these things called
maxwell's equations and i'm kind of um
uh
now
uh thinking through there's this
equation that says curl b equals um
a current
um and that's the equation let's think
about this for a second um
i'm now
uh
yeah this is this is terrible i i
i'm
let me think about this how does this
work
so
we need um
the this
essentially what's happening is the
magnetic field is causing electrons to
move which is causing an electric
current
and the reason
that
that
you
can
heat something up
something like a metal up
is that the electrons are
move fairly easily in the metal so when
you have a certain amount of force
that's moving the electrons you can get
the electrons to move and as the
electrons
collide with with them well and
as they as they lose energy they
transfer heat to the metal and the
electrons kind of never get started
moving in something that isn't uh
something that isn't a metal or
something that isn't an electrical
conductor um i this is this is um i'm
going to punt on this slightly and um
uh maybe we'll come back to this one
um
this is this is uh
um
it's always um as i say always
suspicious but any questions seems like
it's it's going to be easy all right we
have another physics one here from from
cap
how does a shortwave radio signal go
completely around the world
so
when when i was a kid
you know i had a radio and it had
different frequency bands
and
some frequency bands in like the early
evening you would be able to
hear
radio stations that were significant
parts of the way around the world
what happens is
that
so normally
in when you just have a radio signal it
will
just just like when you so
radio is a form of electromagnetic wave
just like light as a form of
electromagnetic wave radio has a much
longer wavelength than light
with light you shine a light
there's
it it
uh
the the light can go if it's just going
through something transparent like air
the light just goes in essentially in a
straight line
and if you can see the light so to speak
then the light gets to you if you can't
see the light then the light is blocked
and so it's kind of line of sight
transmission of from the source to the
receiver now it gets a little trickier
because of the phenomenon of diffraction
if you have
light is ultimately a wave although its
wavelength is very short radio is also a
wave but its wavelength can be a lot
longer what happens in diffraction if
you imagine
a um a bunch of let's say water waves
and the water waves are getting too um
uh
they they get to let's say
some
imagine you have a a whole line of
parallel water waves and they get to
sort of the entrance to a harbor let's
say and and they're blocked so so some
part of that of that parallel line of
water waves gets stopped only the middle
part let's say of the parallel line of
water waves gets through so now the
question is when you have that parallel
line of water waves just going all in
one direction and you block out part of
the part of that parallel line of water
waves
does the stuff that's in the middle that
gets through does it just go in a
straight line with those water waves
just keeping on going as they were going
and
not does it just go as if it was sort of
a shadow from the from the walls so to
speak and just keep going like that or
does something different happen well the
answer is something different happens
the thing will spread slightly as it
gets past you know when it gets put
through past the wall instead of just
going out sort of as if the thing was
was shadowed by the wall it will spread
out um from uh from the sides at a
certain certain angle why does it do
that
essentially the way to think about it is
that there's a thing called huygens
principle which basically says that when
you have something like a wave
you can think of things you can think of
kind of the the source of making a wave
as being every point on the wave is sort
of making a new piece of wave and every
point is making kind of a circular piece
of wave it's like it's like you drop a
stone somewhere and you'll see these
circular waves produced well every
the the the every
as you form waves every piece of wave um
is
is forming new wave in that same kind of
way like it's making a circular uh
circular area of wave but when you have
those circular areas of wave all being
made at all the different points on this
on this plane wave on this parallel
collection of wave fronts when you do
that and you add all those things up you
just get another parallel wavefront but
you don't get that when the thing was
blocked instead there a piece of this
kind of circular wave can still sort of
keep going because there was just no
other wave that there was nothing else
there there's no other source of of
wavelet so to speak um outside of that
region where where they where the uh uh
where which hadn't been blocked and so
what will happen is a phenomenal
diffraction
where you get a sort of a spreading uh
where the where you you get waves that
go um that go off at an angle away from
the place where sort of the pure kind of
following the rays kind of um
uh propagation of of things would go
so in general the amount of diffraction
depends on the wavelength
of
uh what you're dealing with and so and
typically when you have kind of an
opening that is uh um kind of
comparable in size to the wavelength the
distance between the wave fronts
then there will be uh there'll be more
diffraction and when you have a um
an opening that's that's huge compared
to the distance between wave fronts the
amount of diffraction the diffraction is
kind of by by about one wave front
in in direction so to speak and so if
the if the if if the kind of opening is
is huge compared to the distance between
wave fronts it will not be a significant
effect if it's small compared to the
distance between wavefronts it will be a
big effect
so for light we have to go down
to um uh to the scale of of billionths
of a meter in things to get to the point
where we have significant diffraction
effects for radio waves because the the
wavelength can be much longer
diffraction is a more significant thing
so in in that means that there are when
you have transmission of radio waves for
example for
um uh for cell phones and things
diffraction is a significant effect um
you can it is not the case that the the
uh radio waves uh are just going purely
in a straight line if they hit an
obstacle there will be some diffraction
around that obstacle so in a sense you
get to to see a bit around corners that
way
okay so that's that's sort of what
normally happens is radio except for
diffraction radio basically is just
going in a straight line from source to
receiver just like light does um but now
so now the the issue is that that that
happens so long as there's nothing that
acts as a mirror if there's something
that acts as a mirror as we know from
light light can hit a mirror and bounce
off and so like you can think about the
photons of in the light little particles
of light or the wave that corresponds to
light light behaves both like a stream
of photons and kind of like a wave
that's a that's another story about how
that sort of those two complementary
views of light work together um but but
either way what's happening is we can
think about it like particles like
photons the photons hit the mirror and
they bounce off just like a billiard
ball will bounce off a um a um
uh
the side of a table or something and
what's happening is and and so the the
and what typically happens is
what what causes a photon of light to
bounce off something as opposed to just
to get absorbed so for example you know
you shine light on some
some i don't know a piece of black paper
or something the light basically just
gets absorbed in the black paper you
shine light on a nice polished piece of
metal the the light will typically be
reflected like a mirror why does that
happen well what's happening is that
what
when the light when the photon hits the
material what it's doing is it's getting
absorbed by an atom in the material so
the photon hits the atom it causes the
atom to go into a higher energy state
and the atom then after a short time
will decay back to its low energy state
it will re-emit a photon
so in other words there's there's a
photon that is being um
that's uh
um that when when the when the photon
hits the material it's causing the
material it's causing something about
the material to just absorb the energy
of the photon and then the material uh
loses that energy by re-emitting a
photon again so the question is how easy
is it for the material to do that
so there are fundamentally two
so-called dielectrics materials that
don't um uh that
aren't um
uh that that
don't don't uh conduct electricity and
conductors like metals that do and so
the way that works is in a conductor
well the electrical current is a bunch
of electrons flowing from here to there
in a metal there are lots of electrons
that are just sort of hanging around so
the metal the material the metal is is
some array of atoms and each atom has
some electrons associated with it and
the question is do the electrons that
are associated with different atoms are
they tightly bound to each individual
atom or are the electrons kind of a
shared sea of electrons
shared between all these different atoms
what happens in a metal is that the
electrons essentially the in a sense the
atoms are sort of close enough together
and the electrons are far enough away
from their nuclei and so on that the
that you get this kind of whole
sea of electrons where basically the
electrons instead of being
you know very much attached to one
particular atom can kind of float freely
through the metal and so the result of
that is it's much easier to get sort of
to change the state of an electron it's
a much lighter object among other things
than it is to sort of change the state
of an atom or rather it's it's easier
for when so when when you have a photon
that um uh interacts with the metal what
it's interacting with is electrons in
the metal um initially and it is much
easier for the elect for the photon to
get re-emitted um in uh uh to to sort of
uh
get get remitted in such a way that it
bounces like a mirror there's a there's
a little bit more detail to how that
actually works but in rough terms it's
kind of how easy was it for the photon
to get absorbed and re-emitted um sort
of quickly by the material and to what
extent did it kind of go into the
material get absorbed by an atom and
then the atom sits around and thinks
about and eventually re-emits the
re-emits the electron um
the uh
or remits the photon or perhaps even
doesn't perhaps what happens is that the
um uh that the atom just goes into this
um uh perhaps it emits a different
photon not one that was just like the
photon that came in any case that's
that's how things work with metals
normally in the atmosphere we have
the atmosphere doesn't conduct
electricity the air is a pretty good
insulator
when we put enough
voltage across the air eventually it
will um
it will transmit electric current
through breakdown of the air and that's
what lightning is for example what is
breakdown of the air what's happening is
that when you're trying to push an
electric current through the air mostly
the atoms just have their electrons
firmly attached to them and the
electrons aren't moving anywhere to make
an electric current but if you push them
hard enough the electrons will get
stripped away from the nuclei of the
atoms and they'll be able to do kind of
like what happens in a metal and the
electrons will be able to sort of move
and that's what happens in a lightning
strike is that the there's enough
voltage that it's kind of pushing hard
enough the electric field associated
with is is pushing hard enough to push
the electrons out of atoms and to have
them start moving sort of from atom to
atom so to speak
and you're forming when you sort of rip
electrons away from
the um from their atoms you are forming
a plasma where you have like like like
it happens in fire and things like that
where the electrons are no longer um
that where again you can have something
a little bit like what happens in a
metal where the electrons are much more
free-floating than they normally are
sort of normally and they're sort of
attached to the nucleus of an atom
so what happens is in the um
uh
in the earth's atmosphere there's this
thing called the ionosphere the
ionosphere is a region of the earth's
atmosphere high up uh how high is it
it's probably you know
it's higher than planes fly for sure um
and uh but it's in the very very outer
part of the earth's atmosphere
is um uh has the feature that
what's happened is as a result of of
bombarding
with um
uh
ultraviolet light in particular um i
think i think that's the primary thing
that does it um the the atoms have their
the atoms of oxygen and nitrogen and so
on in the air have their electrons kind
of stripped away from them and that
causes them to act as a plasma and the
electrons are kind of free floating and
when the electrons are free floating
like that it behaves much more like a
metal
and in the sense that it can reflect
electromagnetic waves much like a mirror
would reflect them and so what's
happening in shortwave radio
is that you are seeing the the the radio
wave hits this thing it's called the
appleton layer um it's part of the
ionosphere um and it hits that that is
sort of behaving like a a mirror of
radio waves it bounces back down and
then keeps bouncing now actually an
interesting question is why does it
bounce
back
an additional time from the earth's
surface i am actually not sure maybe
when it maybe if it's some uh
water also well i'm not sure how that
works for sure you can i uh one bounce
is easy to understand but i think maybe
there are additional bounces within the
ionosphere that i think that's right i
think that's what happens that that um
once the radio wave so the radio
transmitter is transmitting this radio
wave the radio waves going in all
different directions some of that radio
energy gets up into the uh into the
ionosphere i think it bounces around
there and it kind of keeps bouncing
there
and that that means that it doesn't it
can sort of go round corners around the
earth because it's kind of bouncing and
this thing that's kind of like a wave
guide where it's where the where the
radio wave just keeps bouncing there and
eventually enough of it sort of gets
gets gets kind of gets out at the other
end so to speak that you can
detect it even if you're far away from
the original source
all right so that was my attempt at um
uh at describing shortwave radio and and
by the way the um
uh
the question of why
so this phenomenon of whether it can
bounce or not
depends on
it's the same kind of question as do you
have a material the material might be
it might
look red for example what does it mean
when something looks red what it means
is that if you illuminate it with white
light white light is a combination of
all different colors
it means that if something looks red it
means that it is reflecting red light
back to you and absorbing other colors
like blue light for example
and so in general this question about
what colors get reflected what colors
get absorbed is a question that's the in
in the in the language of physics that's
the that's the imaginary part of the
refractive index so refractive index
tells you things about how light gets
transmitted through a material it tells
you the the the real part of the
refractive index
tells you how much light is slowed down
as it goes through a material so for
example in water it's about a refractive
index about 1.33 which means that light
is going 1.33 times slower
why does that happen it happens because
uh the the light is going through the
water by being uh absorbed by an atom
then the atom re-emits it but there's a
short delay before the atom re-emits it
and that's that it's that delay that
kind of slows down the transmission of
light in water and does that by a factor
of 1.33 for water for glass it's like
1.5 etc etc etc diamond 2.7 those kinds
of things but the the way that one sort
of describes it in electromagnetic
theory is to say that in addition to the
real part of the refractive index we're
just slowing things down there's also an
imaginary part and it works that way
because of its e to the i
times the the the
frequency times time and so on and times
the refractive index and and that um if
it's if the refractive index has an
imaginary part that is a a decaying
exponential type thing but the point is
that one then
uh has
the idea of a um
uh
that there can be both something where
the absorption depends on the color of
the light and the and this this um so so
this refractive index can define depend
on frequency so for example it can be
the case in some materials you know red
light goes faster than blue light and so
on that's that's how things like prisms
work that's how they split the colors of
light is because um one one color of
light is going faster so bends more or
less than another color but so similarly
there's a variation in the amount of
absorption that happens depending on the
frequency and so the same is true with
the plasma there's a there's a whole
plasma dispersion function it's called
that has to do with what uh what
frequency of radio will be absorbed or
transmitted in what way by a particular
kind of plasma and it's that's the
reason that uh
radio waves of some frequencies can
successfully um uh get get reflected by
um this uh
layer of of the ionosphere and others
cannot
now another question which i should know
the answer to and don't immediately but
i let me think about this for a second
is that the best time i think for
shortwave radio is like early evening i
believe and i think the reason for that
is it depends on light from the sun
producing this effect in the ionosphere
and probably a little bit more thought
we could we could figure out why uh why
uh the early evening is the best time
for that
all right let's see
let's try something else here oh so many
other questions
um
okay there's a question from ernesto
will new logical mathematics operators
be invented or discovered
so
we talk about i'm not sure necessarily
what one means by logical mathematics
operators
um
things
when we talk about
uh in in logic for example we'll be
typically talking about you know p
or q p and q
if p
is a proposition that says you know it's
raining today or something and q is a
proposition that says
it's raining tomorrow or something like
that we can say p and q
and that represents that combination of
logical statements
now when you ask what are the different
possible combinations if you have two
possible truth values true or false
it's not hard to work out that there are
just 16 possibilities for if one thing's
true the other thing's false then the
result might be true and if one thing if
they're both true the result might be
false or whatever there are only 16
possible cases um
many of them but not all of them have
names you know and says if they're both
true then it's true if either of them is
false then it's false
or says if either of them is true then
it's true only if uh both of them are
false is it false but there are more
exotic ones like nand
is uh if it's the not of the and
of of the two things and there are
different possibilities they're
different kind of truth tables you can
make where you're saying given that this
is true that's false and so on there are
um uh there are
uh let's see there are
uh 16 well there there are four
possibilities for saying uh the first
thing is true the second thing is false
the first thing is false the second
thing is true and so on there are four
different cases true true true false
false true false false and for each of
those you have to say is the result
going to be true or is it going to be
false
and there are two to the four or 16
possible ways to do that
and as i say some of those things have
an easy kind of interpretation in our
language like and or or and things like
that and others do not but that's kind
of a very complete thing where we kind
of kind of easily enumerate what the
possibilities are now if we start saying
we'll include not just true or false but
also maybe and we'll make up some kind
of calculus for two maybes uh you know
maybe and maybe makes maybe and so on
then we can have uh so-called
multi-valued logic and then there's many
more possibilities
but that's kind of a pretty complete
setup now when you talk about
mathematics
there are things that you might do with
numbers like you say well i'm going to
add two numbers together great okay
that's plus sign we're all good we can
if you iterate adding numbers together
you get multiplication okay we
understand that you you iterate
multiplication you get powers and so on
these are all well understood kind of
operators that combine numbers but if
you've got two numbers there are all
kinds of crazy exotic things you could
do with those numbers for example one
thing you could do is you could say
let me take the two numbers let me
reverse the digits in one of the numbers
and let me add the corresponding digits
with the other number that's a totally
weird operation we don't have a a
typical name or notation for that
operation because that operation is
something that's kind of amusing to look
at and it does some wild things but it's
not an operation that we generally find
useful
so when you have something like numbers
um there are certain operations that
seem to be things that
are useful in our world to do with
numbers and there are others that don't
seem so useful you can kind of grind the
number up in a variety of different ways
and sort of do operations on its pieces
like it's digits for example um and uh
and that's kind of a a a thing
that that doesn't seem to correspond to
things which are kind of useful in
everyday life
now occasionally
um there are
uh there are exotic uses for things like
that question of taking a number and
reversing its digits you might say
that's a useless thing to do
it's actually in things called fast
fourier transforms that's something that
is as part of how how one hooks up um
how one decides how to combine
uh uh
combine data together is all based on
doing things like reversing the digits
of numbers although that isn't a normal
kind of operation
and in general if you just say given
numbers could we invent a bunch of
really exotic operations that will work
for any pair of numbers
but
uh then the answer is we can invent an
infinite number of those kinds of things
a question is which ones will be useful
to us i think that's actually a fairly
deep philosophical question
because i think it has to do with how do
we typically experience the world what
kinds of things do we think are
important in the world
let me give an example
there are cases
in uh
well let's see there are
there are phenomena
um
let's see what's the simplest case of
this there are phenomena in physics
where you do get to kind of grind up the
digits of numbers to some extent
so a typical case of that would be
something like this
imagine
that
you are
well let's see the most common thing is
a thing called the well cantoset
fractals these are all related and
essentially what's happening is you say
i'm going to try and decide i'm going to
color things black or white
and maybe i just say it's half black
it's half white okay that's
straightforward um but maybe i do
something where i nest different areas
within this area of black i'm going to
have an area of white within the area of
white i'm going to have an area of black
and i keep nesting this i keep on keep
on nesting nesting nesting that so i get
these tiny little areas where it's it's
white and tiny area and areas where it's
black and i have this kind of hierarchy
of progressively larger areas where it's
black or white that makes a typical kind
of nested or fractal pattern and if i
ask the question at any given point
am i going to get black or white the
answer to that question may depend on
some digit in the number that represents
the position of that point so a fairly
typical thing to do
is oh for example you might say digits
in base 10 and you might say if the
digit if the number contains any
uh threes sevens or fives in its digit
expansion a point you know one two one
one seven two four six four et cetera et
cetera et cetera if if that digit
expansion contains any three sevens or
fives let's say then don't allow that
number and then ask the question what
does what what do you get if you do that
the answer is you'll get this
complicated nested pattern with all
kinds of little tiny dots of you know
pieces of white and black if black has
numbers you allow and whites as numbers
you don't allow and so on so that's a
case where sort of
even
where if you have that kind of nested
behavior then that's a way to sort of
get something which depends on weird
features of numbers
how do you get nested behavior well for
instance
if you have anything that's a branching
structure
whether it's a tree branching or whether
it's the the kind of pathways in our
lungs branching or any of these kinds of
things we have any kind of branching
structure and you say what's the end
result of all that branching you will
get something that's this kind of nested
structure um where these kinds of things
would happen so there are cases there
where you can imagine other kinds of
ways to process numbers that are rather
different from the kind of usual
arithmetic kinds of ways to process
numbers like ways to process numbers
where it matters whether there's ever a
three digit in the number even
arbitrarily far far
arbitrarily uh sort of uh
low order place so to speak
so
but i think this question of what is it
that our senses notice about things like
numbers
that's something where we notice certain
kinds of things but we don't notice
other kinds of things and insofar as
we're interested in doing operations on
numbers that are about things we notice
um the that's um uh that's why we end up
with these fairly small number of
operations that we've been doing for
four thousand years at least
um
that uh are typically on numbers until
you get to sort of higher questions in
mathematics
actually we have another related
question here from elgirs why do we have
two different kinds of things numbers
plus operators data spots algorithms we
represent many things with those things
why not three why not four why not one
okay
so
often when you think about
doing things with computers
you think about there's just data it's
just i've got a number it's sitting
there nothing's happening with it
and there's also algorithms where you're
doing things on the number you're adding
numbers together you're you're doing
operations
so it it feels as if there's two very
different kinds of things there's data
that just sits there and there's
algorithms that
sort of
process things and change them
well i don't think they're quite as
different as that if you even think
about how the computer works inside that
number that's just sitting there in the
memory of the computer it's actually
continually being refreshed so you can
think of it as well there is actually an
operation going on for that data
it is like an algorithm it just happens
to be a rather trivial algorithm where
all the algorithm does is to copy what
it had before and that's the way that
kind of you propagate that number
through time
so i think that the idea that there's
sort of a a sharp distinction between
that which is just sitting there as data
and that which is algorithmic and being
processed that isn't really such a sharp
distinction actually interestingly in
our theory of physics
that now
one of the things that we realize is
that the whole structure of the universe
is based on this sort of giant network
of kind of atoms of space
and what's happening
throughout time the progress of time is
associated with a series of kind of
update events that update this giant
network and so in fact there wouldn't
even be a notion there wouldn't there
wouldn't be anything that the fact that
there's anything that seems persistent
is not trivial it's it's at the level of
sort of the atoms of space things are
continually being rewritten maybe 10 to
the 100 times per second
very very rapidly things are being
rewritten anything that
sort of was a piece of the structure of
the universe
10 to the some trillion trillion
trillions of a second ago is no longer a
piece of the universe
it's no longer exists it has been
replaced by a new version by a new thing
and so the idea that there's data that
gets preserved that has to be something
that is a sort of a bigger feature of
the system not just the individual sort
of atoms of space and and the way that
works is much like i don't know in a
water wave or something there's this
wave that kind of undulates on the
surface of the water but the individual
molecules of water are are not that the
wave is something that is sort of a
collective effect of many molecules of
water the individual molecules of water
are not what's moving when the way when
the wave moves and so on and so it's the
same kind of thing with effects in in
space in the in the fundamental physics
and so i think the way to think about
kind of data versus algorithms is
is it something where you can recognize
that it is persistent that is basically
just oh that's that same number two just
getting copied versus is that something
where it is obviously changing
and there are certainly plenty of
examples where you could imagine
that what it means to be quotes data is
a little bit non-trivial because it
could be the case for example for
example let's say you've got that number
two
and you say okay it's a two
that number two is lodged somewhere in
the memory of your computer okay the way
your computer operates it might decide
oh i'm going to move that too in my
memory i'm going to and then the
question is is it the same two when it
got moved is it just data well actually
at the level of looking at the detailed
operation of the computer it's sort of a
different two because it got moved to
being stored in a different part of the
computer's memory and the the question
is so so in a sense i think it's fair to
say sort of in some sense everything is
algorithms everything it just happens
that some algorithms are trivial and
just uh the the identity algorithm
that's just copying things so i think
that's that's the the sense in which so
in some sense there is only one kind of
thing
which is the the continual updating of
things by virtue of algorithms but that
updating might lead to no no change of
the thing and then we just call it a
piece of data
um
yeah so i think that i think that's
that's the answer to that and that there
really isn't a sharp distinction now now
when you are dealing with kind of
low-level programming languages um
then because of the way computers are
constructed they have a habit of being
set up to have
uh
that to really separate out
the there's just memory here that's just
keeping data and there's an arithmetic
logic unit in the cpu or something
that's processing data and making
changes to it that is really a feature
of the details of how computers have
been made for the past 60 70 years or so
that isn't a fundamental feature of how
things have to be
um it's in fact there are certainly
idealized models of computation and
perhaps more than that when we get to
have molecular scale computation i
suspect that the let's maintain the data
thing
is will be much more algorithmically
non-trivial than it is in in the way
that we at least idealize computers to
work today
so i think that that's some uh
that that's that's kind of the way that
works now in something like mathematics
it's an interesting case as well
in mathematics
we sometimes identify
functions variables
those kinds of things as different kinds
of things
um
that is i think a feature
of kind of the way that mathematics and
algebra and so on evolved
um as we look at more abstract versions
of mathematics through mathematical
logic and more so the kinds of ways that
i've built sort of computational
language structures and so on you stop
seeing this sharp distinction between a
function and a variable for example in
wolfram language if you say
the function f of x
there's really nothing different between
the f and the x you could as well say
the function f of f
you know it's a function of a function
you know function where the where the
thing that it is being applied to the
variable it's being applied to is just
the same kind of thing as the function
and in general in our computational
language um this idea of the the
functions the data the programs the data
they're really all the same kind of
thing they're all represented
symbolically by these expressions that
contain that have a certain structure
and that ultimately refer to symbols
these symbols could represent
a function
like plus
but they could equally well represent
a a thing
like the entity new york city for
example there's no distinction between
the the function plus it's just a symbol
called plus
and you know the the symbol that says i
don't know something like you know now
the current moment in time those are
just those are just symbols and you can
manipulate them as symbolic things and
there's no real distinction made between
them and that's i think the
the the a good way to think about
kind of uh this this sort of merger of
you know how do you break up computation
so we humans can understand it you don't
need to break it up by saying there's
separately a function and an operator
and its operands a thing that's doing
the operation and a thing that's
operating on that distinction is not
necessary that distinction might be
useful for some ways of thinking about
things but it's not a necessary
distinction and it's not even the way
that in our computational language that
things are implemented it's like those
two things are are the same kind of
thing all the way down
let's see
uh
okay there's more of a
um
history question about norbert we know
let me let me move that to my
history of science and technology uh
question
the basic question was
do i know about norbert weiner's work
yes i do quite a bit
um is it relevant to current computer
science at all it was primarily oriented
around this
uh area that got called cybernetics
control and communication in
kind of animals and machines type thing
and um
cybernetics led to control theory it led
to various kinds of things it has not
been as directly relevant specifically
in computer science although perhaps one
could draw lines between that kind of
approach
and um and what's been done in modern
machine learning and so on maybe i can
talk about that more in a in a history
discussion
um
okay there's a question here
oh gosh
um
okay there's a question from aaron
what's the difference between cpus gpus
tpus a6
okay a technology question
all right in
in our computers
there is
a central processing unit a cpu that's
the place that kind of does the work
of doing the computations that our
computer is doing and
the
the way that that work is getting done
is any program on our computer is
eventually represented as machine code
what is machine code machine code
ultimately says there is this
instruction that will be done to this
data for example
and
for example one of those instructions
might be
uh you know add these two numbers
together those two numbers they are
located at this location in memory that
location of memory go fetch the data
from those locations in memory and then
inside the cpu the operation of the cpu
is
let's um uh let's add those two numbers
together which means those numbers are
both represented as sequences of bits
and binary um in our computer and the
addition consists of well doing the same
kind of thing we would we would imagine
doing if we were doing it by hand you're
just adding adding the digits doing
carry bits all those kinds of things and
then getting the results
so in a typical computer there are some
number of tens or hundreds
of fundamental instructions that the
computer knows how to do like adding
numbers like copying a piece of data
from here to there
like uh sending like setting a piece of
memory that might be connected to your
screen to have some particular value so
that some pixel in your screen will
light up those kinds of things
um and there are some number of
so-called opcodes some number of
different intrinsic instructions that
are built into the operation of the
computer and so when a cpu is made it's
this it's this microprocessor this chip
that might have you know uh hundreds of
millions of transistors on it that are
implementing circuits which in the end
will be the things that op code 73
will be
i don't know subtract two numbers and
whenever the program contains opcode 73
that particular part of the circuit that
is the microprocessor that makes your
cpu that it will go to that particular
part of the circuit and it will say okay
run this data through this part of the
circuit and get the result from opcode73
and usually there's there's some
it's called the decoder tree where
you're basically taking the op codes
which are themselves represented as
numbers and you're saying okay this is
opcode73 that means i'm going to take
the data that's being used for this
opcode i'm going to shuttle it off to
this part of the cpu i'm going to do the
operations that correspond to the
circuit in that part of the cpu i'm
going to get the result back and
keep going and executing the program
so in a cpu
the the typical story is over the course
of time people have invented a
collection of opcodes that they find
useful
there had come a time when people had
hundreds and hundreds of different op
codes that would do very complicated
things like uh would uh evaluate
polynomials they would do all kinds of
things that were very very ornate
operations and those things were burnt
into the hardware of the cpu chip so in
addition to adding numbers it might be
evaluate
a number x squared plus one that might
have been one of the op codes in cpu
in the 1980s there was a big movement to
make so-called reduced instruction set
computers where the idea was actually
have a much smaller number of operations
of intrinsic op codes that the computer
knows how to do because any time you're
computing x squared plus one you can
always do that by doing a series of
other operations you do x times x plus
one
that will be a series of of sort of
lower level simpler op codes and so what
people had done people had originally
thought oh if we put if we burn into the
hardware computing x squared plus one if
we make a circuit specifically for that
it will be a more efficient way to do
things the idea of reduced instruction
set computers risk architectures was
actually just implement a much smaller
number of opcodes and do it incredibly
efficiently and then leave it up to the
compiler leave it up to the program that
takes the code you write and turns it
into machine code to figure out a really
good way to get the right the best
machine code so that you can do these
operations and and the main thing that
happened was that it was realized that
you could with the compiler with the
arrangement of exactly what kind of
instructions do you want to make exactly
what sequence of instructions do you
want to make in the machine code the
compiler could be really smart
about optimizing exactly which series of
instructions were done to achieve this
operation because because typically when
you work something out
let's say
you know i don't know x plus 1 times x
minus 3 or something that's a bad
example
any kind of
computation there are typically many
ways to get that result from the
computation if you say how do i get that
result by doing these the series of
elementary operations there may be many
different programs many different
sequences of those elementary operations
that will always give the same result
it's kind of like a mathematical theorem
that says you know x plus 1 times x
minus 1 is equal to x squared minus one
you could use that theorem to have two
completely different ways to compute the
same result in your computer and so if
you know exactly how long each operation
is going to take and so on you can
essentially write a piece of software
that will say given this operation that
i want to do let me find the best way to
get that operation done from a series of
machine instructions and so that was
kind of the approach of of uh which is
now really the the dominant approach is
keep the number of
of burnt in machine instructions the op
codes that the cpu really understands
keep that rather small and have the
compiler be clever about figuring out
exactly how to take the code you have
and write it in terms of in terms of
those machine instructions
okay so now
that was kind of idea number one you
have the cpu it has certain instructions
in it now people over the course of time
are always saying but we have this
particular operation we just want to
keep on doing over and over and over
again
and we could write it to be done by a
series of machine instructions in the
cpu but actually we can make a piece of
special purpose hardware
a special circuit that does this
operation much more efficiently so back
in the 1980s for example it was very
common for the cpu of a computer not to
have the built-in capability of doing
floating point arithmetic so it could
deal with integers whole numbers but if
you had the number 3.7 it wouldn't know
how to deal with that number with a
decimal intrinsically there would be
software that would allow it to know how
to do that in terms of integers
basically but it didn't have a way in
the circuitry of the computer to deal
with those numbers that have decimal
points in them and so on so what
happened is people introduced these
things called fpu's floating point units
which were special purpose hardware
which just had a bunch of extra
instructions for dealing with with these
numbers with decimals
so gradually what happened is fpus
gradually absorbed onto cpus as people
figured out how to build cpus with
bigger and bigger circuits and them more
and more transistors and them and so on
it was like well let's just put us put
an fpu right on the cpu chip and then
let's well let's kind of merge the fpu
into the cpu so it was no longer the
case that there were these extra it used
to be the case that there would be extra
instructions and for example a compiler
that was taking uh something in let's
say c code c language or something
ultimately in wolfram language it would
be something which is primarily going
from our top level language down to uh
sort of being interpreting that top
level language in terms of machine
instructions there will be a question if
your computer happens to have an fpu
then say okay we can use these extra
machine instructions to do certain
floating point operations really fast
um and uh so that was kind of a a big
kind of idea of have this co-processor
this fpu that went alongside the cpu
with extra instructions which your
programs could make use of
now
what happened with fpus is
typically when you compile a program
when you take it from let's say c
language code uh down to machine code
then you would be able to set a an
option in your compiler that says i've
got an fpu you can generate fpu
instructions as well as cpu instructions
okay when the fpu got kind of included
in the cpu that no longer was an issue
and um and it all got a bit simpler
okay but now there are other operations
that people often want to do
and um so people
gradually uh
kind of
well actually let me let me let me
address two two pieces here so
there there are okay
what if there's a particular operation
you just want to keep on doing you've
got some video encoder and it does some
particular series of of you know
instructions where you're taking a raise
of numbers and doing this and combining
them in that way etc etc you always want
to do the same thing you say that's a
real waste to do it in in software where
i've just got this series of machine
instructions and i'm doing it like i
would generate from a compiler and so on
so there's this notion of microcode this
was a common thing it's not so common
these days actually
where
okay so so normally
when you execute an instruction in a cpu
there is
you know at least in a rough
approximation and it's gotten a little
bit more complicated in modern times
you're doing one op code at a time you
add the numbers you subtract the numbers
you multiply the numbers et cetera et
cetera et cetera but actually if you
look at your cpu chip there's one area
of the cpu chip that's dealing with
adding numbers there's another area it's
dealing with multiplying numbers there's
another area that's dealing with i don't
know um you know
saving things in memory there's another
area etcetera etcetera etcetera they're
all these separate areas of the cpu
and normally if you're running a program
it's just one op code at a time one area
of the cpu is being used at a time
but
if you want to be really really detailed
you really know how your cpu is set up
you could set it up so that actually
when you have addition going on here on
one side of the cpu you have
multiplication going on here on another
side of the cpu so there's this idea of
microcode which is the idea of having
something which says to the cpu chip it
says i want you to do exactly this kind
of thing where you've got
it's not just the series of op codes
that are sort of centrally decoded up
codes it's like have one part of the
chip do this have another part of the
chip do that and so on and so what's
quite often done is to write
and i guess this has this is done for
some of the important um
libraries for doing certain kinds of
matrix operations things like this
they're written at the level of well we
know exactly how the chip is set up and
so we can say get this side of it to do
this while this side of it is doing this
and you can make it more efficient than
if you just do everything as opcode
opcode opcode in the main part of the
chip
okay so that's a way that you can sort
of improve the performance within an
individual chip but you have to know a
lot of detail about how the chip works
another thing you can do is just make
your own chip you can say i just want
this particular piece of circuitry i'm
going to just keep doing it over and
over again let me just make a chip that
only has that particular piece of
circuitry that's what an asic is an
application specific integrated circuit
so
in that case what you're doing is you're
creating um
the
in the most extreme case you're just
saying i want to make this particular
circuit and i'm going to make a chip
that's based on this particular circuit
and i'm going to manufacture a new chip
and all it does is a piece of video
decoding it doesn't do general purpose
computing it's just intended to do video
decoding now there's a thing in the
middle of that things called fpgas field
programmable gate arrays
and the idea of those is that you have
something where you have sort of a
standardized collection of different
kinds of operations that you can be
doing and you can kind of make your own
circuit by kind of hooking those
together in different ways so you have a
big sort of piece of silicon or whatever
that has this whole array of different
sort of cells that do it different
operations and you get to sort of define
what the wiring is between those parts
um to define what operations you want
your your sort of semi-custom-built chip
to do and that's a very common way to
make asics in in in modern times is
these
fpgas
okay what is a gpu
well
back in the in when people got really
serious about doing graphics operations
for for video games for video encoding
all these kinds of things it became uh
there were these particular operations
and the most common issue is you've got
a whole array of numbers you've got an
image which has a whole bunch of pixels
in it you've got a um
something like that you just want to do
the same operation to all those pixels
and if you were doing that in a standard
cpu you would have a series of
operations where you say do it to one
pixel move another pixel in from memory
do it to that one move another pixel in
from memory do it to that one and so on
but instead you want to do these kind of
vector operations where you say i've got
this whole array of pixels a whole array
of values i just want to do the same
thing to all of them
so
what people started doing was making
special
uh special co-processors gpus graphics
processing units which would have vector
instructions which would have things
where where you would say things like i
want to i want to do this particular
operation on on this whole whole array
of numbers all at the same time and so
typically in a gpu there'll be some set
of these kind of big uh registers big
things where you can keep arrays of
numbers and you just do that do that
same thing to all of them and it's kind
of an art to make up the right kind of
instructions that are the useful
instructions that are the right building
blocks to do let's say video encoding or
something like this
and over time those got invented um
a good friend of mine is involved in in
making up many of of those uh kinds of
instructions for what have become sort
of the common gpus um the uh
it's something where it is you know
you're making up a particular kind of
operation is this thing that
does a particular kind of rearrangement
of the of the elements in this array of
numbers is that useful it's quite
similar to the process of language
design of saying what functions should
we build into our computational language
but it's a much lower level version of
the same kind of thing
so
so what happened with the gpus
is they have these particular operations
these particular instructions now they
don't play as nice with
uh
uh for example
when
the the so the main operations of your
computer the things controlled by your
operating system and so on those are the
the cpu is what does all of that stuff
the gpu is something where
there are particular pieces of
computations that you say that will be
really good if that was done in the gpu
now typical programs
you have to do special work
to to make use of the gpu and there are
different languages different libraries
and things that you use to say i'm going
to make a piece of gpu code it's not
your generic piece of code that that
gets compiled into gpu language that
isn't the way it works it's beginning to
work more like that i have to say i
thought sort of in the evolution of
engineering that the gpu capabilities
would gradually get absorbed into cpus
that hasn't quite happened yet although
some pieces of that have happened but so
gpus tend to be optimized for this sort
of parallel operation you know on these
on these um many many operations done in
parallel across across a sort of whole
array of data
so then there's tpus which i think i
think tpu is a i think probably a google
name for this this idea but it's
basically making um sort of semi-special
purpose uh chips that deal with the kind
of operations that are common in neural
networks for machine learning and so on
those operations are actually build on
the same kinds of operations that are
done in gpus the same kinds of
operations that are done in um
one of the things is there's a lot of
operations that are on arrays of numbers
on matrices linear algebra etc those
kinds of operations are important for
computer graphics they're also important
for the way that neural nets are set up
at least with the way they're set up
right now
and
so but there are particular sort of
variants of that that
are things that you can build special
purpose hardware
to uh to implement and that's what
people have been doing um the various
different uh companies have various
technologies for this that are sort of
special purpose
neural network chips
that uh are specially optimized for
those kinds of things now it's it's it's
a complicated trade-off because the same
thing that happened in risk architecture
people had said oh we want to get this
particular operation to go faster let's
burn that into the cpu let's spend a lot
of effort building up a circuit let's um
but but then our whole cpu might run
slower because we have to have this
extra piece and we've got to deal with
the fact that there's some timing set up
here or there it would be much better to
have a sleeker simpler cpu that was kind
of a risk idea and to kind of have the
software assemble the right sort of
sequence of operations to be done
whether that will happen in the world of
of um of neural networks and so on i'm
not sure i think it's quite possible it
will happen what the trend right now
tends to be more let's put these very
complicated things and burn them into
hardware now of course there's a bunch
of trade-offs here because
as the hardware gets as it gets easier
to make you know the billion transistor
cpu chip as people figure out how to
make very very tiny transistors you know
that are that are i don't know five
nanometers across or whatever else it is
as people figure out how to do make much
smaller components you can put more
transistors more detail of circuit um on
this chip and it becomes less of an
issue to say oh let's build in this
special weird thing that does this
particular kind of operation that's
needed in this exotic kind of neural net
it's like why not we can put another 100
000 transistors on this chip no problem
it's not going to cost any extra but as
it depends on the engineering trade-offs
whether it's a better idea to say no no
let's keep our chip really sleek and
simple and let's kind of build up all
the complexity on the software side so
that's kind of kind of the idea of these
these different kinds of um
uh of of ways to implement i mean it's
all about how do you how do you actually
make your computer compute
and uh in the end
any one of these things the sort of the
the the amazing thing about software
is and the amazing thing about universal
computation is even given
given one of these kinds of uh
computational systems it's always at
least in principle possible to write a
program for it that will do anything
so for example with our cpu we can
probably write a program that will do
exactly what our fanciest tpu will do
there's a trade-off it takes longer to
run potentially because for example the
program um has it's running different
pieces one after the other sequentially
whereas if you knew more detail about
how the chip was set up and you made
these very fast pathways on the chip you
could run things in parallel and make
them much faster so there are these
trade-offs but in the end the the
ultimate computations you can do but for
timing
are are all the same and in the end
timing tends to be driven by things like
uh physical processes that are going on
you know can it can the car figure out
which way to turn you know fast enough
to make a difference so to speak or can
we get this video fast enough that we
humans sort of uh uh
you know fuse the frames together and it
looks like a continuous video and so on
all right i think um
uh i need to
go in a moment maybe i'll try one more
question if i can see
um
uh
okay a bunch more physics questions
um which i'm happy to do
my gosh there's a question about dogs
and hearing loss and i'm afraid that one
i would i don't i don't know offhand i
can make guesses but i don't think
that's that's what i should do
um
all right i'll take i'll do one more
okay
um
from mar here
how viable is a big numerical reverse
database to identify closed forms for
real numbers
such as simon pluff's inverter
okay
this is kind of interesting one maybe
okay
you've got the number 1.2736846
what is it
where did it come from you could just
write it down but it could be that that
number is actually pi squared over seven
it could be that that number has a short
sort of symbolic description
that number might be the square root of
two we can write it very easily or that
number might be something which we could
describe as one point four one four
eight six three four two four five et
cetera et cetera et cetera it's a number
that just seems like a random number
so some numbers
a very small fraction
of all numbers can be described easily
so for example with rational numbers
like two-thirds point six six six six
six six six recurring that's a definite
thing if we just change one of those
sixes out of the billionth digit
we wouldn't that wouldn't no longer be
two-thirds and we might have no
particularly simple way to describe if
we just change one digit there's a
pretty easy way to do it by just adding
adding one one over blah blah blah but
to one over ten to the blah blah blah
but but if we if we monkeyed around with
a bunch of digits out there there might
be no simple description of that number
so that the question is which numbers so
which numbers have simple descriptions
first thing to realize is the fraction
of numbers that are rational numbers
okay so we have whole numbers and we
have rational numbers which are ratios
of whole numbers so you know three
quarters seven eighths et cetera et
cetera et cetera a little bit of a
trickiness with rational numbers already
that uh you know 4 6
which seems like it's a definite number
is actually the same as the number two
thirds that's that we can we can cancel
the the extra factor of two and so what
we might think of oh you write down a
number any two numbers written down
differently will be different numbers
but it isn't true for rational numbers
even though those two numbers are
written down differently four over six
and two over three they're actually the
same number they're equal they're
numerically equal numbers
and and by the way there's a there's an
even bigger trickiness which is if we
write down numbers as decimals the
number 0.9999999
nines all the way down is that number
the same as the number 1.000
or not those numbers can be arbitrarily
small different
are they in fact the same number for
most purposes of mathematics those are
the same number even though their
representation is different and that
causes all kinds of difficulty in
understanding how real numbers numbers
with which aren't just whole numbers
work
so
the question is
which well i was going to say if you ask
the question
is every possible number a rational
number the answer is no you can when you
have sufficiently many digits any
rational number is ratio of two integers
and if the integer has as as it's kind
of a limiting thing if we say they're an
infinite number of digits
we can't get to the at infinite number
of digits with integers it just doesn't
work that way there's there's more
there's more uh
there's more real numbers than there are
integers
if you call the number of integers it
has a name it's called lf0 it's uh it's
a so-called transfinite cardinal is is
the number of integers now that number
you can't like i can't give you that
number of of m ms or something um that
number is just a theoretical number it's
really an infinite number but it's a
particular kind of infinite number lf0
uh it turns out that the the number of
of um
uh uh the number of real numbers is is
about is is basically two to the l of
zero basically you're you're for every
um
there's a there's a higher level of
infinity that you get to um that
corresponds to the um uh to the real
numbers
so in a sense that means there are many
more real numbers than there are
rational numbers
but even if but so the question is if
you have a number that comes out of a
calculation and you say i wonder whether
and that number what you got by some
numerical computation method and you say
i wonder i've generated 50 digits of
this number i wonder whether actually
that number is pi squared over 7 whether
actually that number is something that
can be represented in a simple symbolic
way where if i had been smarter about
doing the calculation and had done it
kind of algebraically rather than
numerically i would have just got the
answer pi squared over seven i wouldn't
have got this big block of numbers
okay so the question is is there a
systematic way to say
what's the number that what given a
series of digits
is it
uh is it even close to a nice to
describe number
okay the tricky part of this is there's
this complicated trade-off what's a nice
to describe number if this number was
equal to to let's say
two over square root of 3.
that's like okay that's fairly nice but
it's also really close to pi to the 17
over 742 minus
the zeta function of 5 plus whatever you
say well that's not quite so nice
um but and you say i'd really prefer to
get the two over square root of three
form even if
when i
that might be a little bit further away
from the actual digits that i have or
might not agree for as many digits or
something but so there's this question
of can you assess
what is a you know what is the likely
nice number that might have been the
nice to describe number that might be
close to this real number that you have
now more from alpha for example if you
just type in some random number it will
try and tell you
nice possible closed forms closed form
meaning something where you can just say
the whole thing you can just say it's pi
you're not saying three point one four
one five nine dot dot dot dot and you
don't say the whole thing um a closed
form is something where you just say as
sort of the symbolic
representation of it as
it's square root of two it's you know
uh
pi to the power e or something um now
you know how does one do that well
there is a trade-off how exotic do the
formulas get um how many terms do the
formulas have and then what kinds of
things appear in the formulas i
mentioned two okay that's pretty pretty
communal garden i mentioned pi
okay that's a little bit more exotic i
mentioned e that's a little even more
exotic let's say i mentioned the golden
ratio
let's say i mention
the catalan the catalans constant i
could start giving you all these named
things which have occurred in the
history of mathematics but they get more
and more obscure and so the question is
if i've got a trade-off if i say well
this thing is really close to catalan's
constant cubed over six it's also
roughly square root of three
which would you pick
well or actually worse it's equal to
catalan's constant over two or it's this
combination of eight square roots which
do you pick
you kind of have to have this measure of
what is the what is the sort of lowest
information content thing
in other words if if catalan's constant
requires you to know all this extra
stuff from the history of mathematics to
know about it that's kind of a higher
cost than if it's a few more square
roots
so actually in wolfram alpha what we did
is when we're trying to assess the
relative importance or relative sort of
complexity of these different kinds of
constants let's say we just searched the
mathematical literature and we said the
more frequently the thing occurs the
less obscure it is and the lower the
kind of cost of producing it and formula
is
but there will be cases where there's a
very very obscure constant but uh you
know you might really nail this result
by using that obscure constant but you
could also get a good approximation by
using some much more a slightly more
complicated formula with ordinary
constants so so basically that's the
idea that you have to you have to kind
of have this way of waiting these
different pieces that you could put into
your formula and say which ones are more
important than which other ones from a
technical point of view i mean we've
done a pretty good job i think with with
the one of these involved in alpha um
the difficulty is more of a
philosophical difficulty of kind of how
do you represent you know each one of
these things that's the such and such
constant is essentially a packaging of
certain ideas in mathematics where you
say and the result is
such and such a function or such and
such a
a thing and you give that function a
name that's saying this thing wherever
it came from we now know it as this
particular name and we can refer to it
in that way and it's a question of sort
of what did you package in mathematics
to provide in this form
all right
well um we should wrap up here thank you
very much for lots of interesting
questions
i am
duly humbled by my failure to nail our
first question about induction uh maybe
we'll come back to that another time
and uh
thanks for all the interesting questions
and uh see you again another time
bye for now